hey hi friends welcome to a brand new
series of Linux networking commands my
friend so friends in this series I am
going to cover 50 Linux networking
commands whether you are a Linux
administrator production support
engineer you are application support
engineer you are a devops engineer you
are a developer or if you are a tester
as well or you are from any role 100%
this Linux networking commands is going
to help you and definitely believe me my
friend because there have been lot of
comments are coming where you have
asking sir please do some kind of a
video on Linux Network troubleshooting
and Linux commands my friend so for the
Linux Network troubleshooting I have
already started the video in Linux 100
plus interview question and answer that
is part 13 and in this series I'm going
to show you Linux networking command
almost 50 my friend so in this session
I'm going to show you 10 Linux
networking commands so let's start the
session without wasting much time
because time is money for us my friend
but if you are new to this Channel
please don't forget to like share and
subscribe the channel and press the Bell
icon for the latest notification my
friend so let's start the session so the
first command is my friend that is if
config if config command is used to
display network interface information
let's see if
config so here you can see as soon as I
run I have config it's going to give me
the interface information that is my IP
information and the loop back address my
friend so friends the next command so
friends the next command is your IP
address so IP address so command is used
to
show slash manipulating routing devices
policy routing and tunnels my friend let
me show you see as as soon as I run this
IP address so command you can see it's
not only giving the Lo back address your
interface address but there are some
additional information my friend okay so
let's move on to the next command my
friend so the next command is Route
hyphen n command this display or
manipulate the IP routing
table let's clear this
one and run
route hyph n so clearly you can see my
friend as soon as you run the route
hyphen n command you are able to see
your gateway right and some other
information my friend okay and if you
wanted to know more about
roundout command then you can use hyphen
hyen help command also and you can do a
man and you can do a route also my
friend
okay so here you can come to know see
it's clearly written so whatever the
information I'm providing to you that is
absolutely legitimate and authentic okay
so you'll not get this information
anywhere my friend okay so you can see
the same thing I have put in the slides
also my friend okay so let's move on to
the next
command so friends the next command is
absolutely a ping command and ping
command is used to send icmp EO request
to the network host
so here I am going to show you one real
time example and this website is my own
website which I have created and I have
hosted it on a hostinger my friend and
it's absolutely fully functional website
so this is a real time live project for
you my friend okay so you can see ping
Earth original.com you can see this
particular website is pinging and if I
can take you through so you can see this
website my friend this is my own own
website and even if somebody I have
still work is going on on this website
soon this going this website is going to
be in production and anyways now also if
you can go and if you order something I
have integrated the payment Gateway and
everything you can buy also my friend
okay so this is my own website my friend
even if you want to know who is the CEO
of this company you can clearly see it's
ran my
friend I have
okay so it's clearly working so friends
the next command is your press path
command you have seen like I have asked
one question that what is the difference
between Trace path and trace route okay
so you know see this is what I have
given here it traces the network path to
the destination discovering MTU along
this path it uses UDP Port okay use user
datagram protocol or some random Port my
friend it is similar to trace root
however it does not require any super
user privilege and has no fancy option
this is the basic difference between
Trace root and Trace path command and
even if you
go if you if you run this like this just
run a trace okay so if you do a to so if
you do a double tap so you come to know
there is command coming tress path there
is no tress rout is coming in rhl 9 so
what I suggest press path you just use
my friend
okay and just give your website address
so you can see where your packet is
dropping everything you can see
straightforward without having any
options my friend in Trace root we need
to put some options and we need super
user privilege but this command I'm
executing as a normal user without
having any fancy option over here so you
can see this one my friend so friends
let's move on to the next command the
next command is net startat command so I
would suggest my friends this next uh
net startat command is already
deprecated okay so better you should go
with asss command okay so you can see I
have written that SS is used to dump
socket statistic same way here also if
you want to know the port number or
anything your socket information then in
that case we use net stat command my
friend and it allows showing information
similar to net stack that is what it can
display more TCP and state information
than other tool my friend so here I am
using both you can use SS hyphen a I'm
going to show you both command what is
the difference and a stands for display
all sockets you stands for your display
only UDP socket my friend so here you
can see first I'm going going to show
you net stack right hyphen a so you can
see you are going to get this
information my friend okay and if you
run the command called SS hyphen it's
going to give you a detail information
of your socket all socket
and that is what a stands for your
display all sockets U stands for display
only UDP sockets my friend
and if you do man SS okay just see here
it's clearly written asset is used to
this one it allows to the similar uh to
net stack it can only display more TCP
and state information than other tool
and you can use SS command my friend
because why net startat is already
deprecated okay so it's better to use SS
command my
friend so friends let's move on to the
next command that is asss command only
to display your socket statistics with
hyphen t l PN what does it mean t stands
for display only TCP sockets you stands
for display only UDP sockets L stands
for display listening sockets P stands
for so process using socket n stands for
don't resolve service names let's run
this command and we'll see how it's
giving the output so SS hyphen t u l PN
so you can see
we are getting the information in this
form my friend where what you are
receiving what you are sending what is
the local address Port what is the pr
address port and the process and the
state and your net ID my friend
okay so friends let's move on to the
next command you I think most of you
know about this command that is host
name it's going to show outside the
systems host name my friend so let me
clear this one ifine host name so I'm
going to get a local host local domain
why I'm not getting any name over here
and host command can be used with host
CTL also to set the host name so this is
why I told you if you want to display
the host name you can use host name and
even if you have to set a set set a host
name that also you can do it with the
host name CTL command my friend okay but
one more thing uh that is what I wanted
to show you why we are not uh getting
any host name the reason behind that one
once you do cad/ Etc hosts file there
will be a host files so here you can see
there is a no entry for the host and if
you see cad/
Etc
res.com there is no name server is set
over here okay this is the Gateway only
I have not created any DNS server so for
that I need to create a DNS server that
say name DNS server I have to make an
entry over here and then I need to set
my Local Host local domain my friend
okay means my host name I need to set it
over here right so this is why if you
run the host name command I'm not
getting any output over here right so
let's move on to the next command my
friend the next command is di command
and it is used to DNS lookup utility so
if you do a dig same it's my own website
AR original.com if I do this one so you
can see a detailed information of your
it's a DNS
utility okay and it's going to give me a
detail information of my DNS okay my
friend so let's move on to the next
command my
friend the next command is NS lookup
command so now you'll understand what is
the difference between D command and NS
lookup command my friend so NS lookup
command is used to query internet name
server in interactively okay so same
thing I'm going to run NS look up and
then so now you understand the
difference my friend it's resolving the
DNS clearly over here and in case of dig
we are getting a detailed information
this is the basic difference between D
command and NS lookup Command right I'm
ending up the session here only thank
you for watching this video for more
videos like this please just stay tuned
to my channel and please don't forget to
like share and subscribe the channel and
press the Bell icon for the latest
notification please do take care of your
loved ones till then Jin and bye-bye my
friend